now to south africa where the government
says it's sending some 25 000 soldiers
into regions wracked by looting and
violence boosting the troop deployment
by tenfold
unrest has raged in parts of the country
for almost a week now
and what's being called south africa's
worst violence since the end of
apartheid
ministers are pleading for people not to
take justice
into their own hands
what could be confused for scenes of
bustling commerce
are actually scenes of chaos
in the eastern city of durban looting
arson and riots have continued at scale
police say they've arrested thousands of
people but many officers
say the situation is still out of
control
highway of death gulf war that's what it
looks like down here if you carry on
further down the road
the cars burnt out red cars on the road
they've looted everything the
factories are burning warehouses are
burning the people are coming by their
thousands to come and loot
but in other parts of the country police
appear to be regaining control
the government has deployed some five
thousand soldiers
to support local law enforcement and is
said to be considering sending more
authorities are concerned however about
reports that some civilians may be armed
and taking matters into their own hands
rounding up suspected looters
and resorting to a form of mob justice
lawmakers say they don't want these
groups to add fire to the already
simmering situation
we understand the consent for community
for their safety
and then their need to protect their
properties we would like to
urge these communities to work with the
law enforcement agencies to stop the
looting
and violence and to operate within the
rule of law
protests began last week after former
president jacob zuma began
serving a 15-month jail term for
contempt of court
but frustration over inequality and
rising unemployment
are seen to be fueling the majority of
the chaos
now with dozens left dead in the
violence many grieving families will be
asking themselves
just how long the lawlessness will last
i'm now joined by journalist varashni
palay in johannesburg
uh virusni south africa has experienced
days of unrest and looting of course
what's the situation like today
well the situation today is that um
people are still feeling very nervous
there's still a lot of chaos
we are seeing scenes that are
reminiscent of the early days of
democracy or before rather when there
was
huge unspread widespread unrest in the
country and for many citizens this is
unheard of and unseen previous riots and
protests have been very limited
which have spread this much is
terrifying for many citizens so
right now what it looks like in south
africa and in provinces like mine which
is affected is that
most of us are barricaded in our homes
we can't get
you know we run out of petrol we um bred
is this the shortages of breed and
there's a lot of supplies that have been
disrupted because of
the violence that is happening in poison
hotel where it started
there have been concerns that food and
fuel may be in short supply in some
areas due to transportation disruptions
any indication of that happening
absolutely um so the port city of durban
which is
where the unrest really started is
really essential to our supply chains in
the country
and so supplies have been really
disrupted up to the economic heartland
where the purchase has also spread to so
we actually can't um there are queues
around the block
for fuel um there isn't as i said before
there isn't bread available there are
bridge shortages because
the the main yeast factory in the
country has been has been affected by
the violence again
in kwazulu-natal which is that the port
area
so because of that because it is a
really key area in terms of
um getting exports from outside the
country from delivering them to the rest
of the country we've seen shortages
starting to happen
i'm curious what are people saying there
about the government's response to the
unrest are they
satisfied with what president cyril
ramaphosa is doing
um absolutely not there's a lot of
frustration
um social media itself is a tinder box
of emotions
and south africans generally are i would
say shocked that nothing more has been
done there is a lot of
unhappiness with the fact that this
seems to be
handled with kid gloves because it
started as a political issue because it
started off
around former president jacob zuma and
people are lying to him
it does seem that the necessary force
wasn't used that the necessary
tools of the state were not deployed
fast enough or soon enough
in fact there is a huge criticism of our
intelligence services
not just on ramaphosa but because the
intelligence services were hollowed out
by years of corruption under former
president jacob zuma so
an intelligent service in a country is
supposed to see this coming these people
planned quite
openly on social media they said they
were going to make the country
ungovernable
and yet nothing happened
to stop this that's a journalist of
rationing pillay in johannesburg
much thanks for ashley and now the army
has been called in to protect businesses
in south africa after several days of
riots
over 1300 people have been arrested and
at least 72 have died
in unrest since the jailing of former
president jacob zuma for contempt of
court
violence and destruction on the streets
of johannesburg
the economic capital of south africa
this shopkeeper is just one of thousands
of petrified business owners
caught up in the looting and vandalism
now spreading across the country
what initially started as a protest
against the incarceration of former
president jacob zuma for contempt of
court
has mushroomed into nationwide unrest
yes we have a lot of poverty and people
did grab the food that they needed
but we've now gone further than that
where we've seen over 200 shopping
centers
uh destroyed we're seeing a lot of
businesses
going out of business we're seeing a lot
of fear and this is going to take years
to come back
and and fix itself so the poverty and
the inequality in south africa is going
to get worse
before it even has a chance to get
better
the south african national defense force
has now been deployed by the government
for only the fourth time in three
decades
to re-establish law and order as
businesses are plundered by angry mobs
that outnumber the country's police
for business owners the help can't come
soon enough
with the majority of those in affected
areas too scared to reopen for trade
you